some call me a trash shocker but I don't
really talk
trash just facts now the best trash
shocker I I would I would go with
somebody like yoke or Luca like Luca
Just Smiles like that's so
disrespectful he what little boy little
[Music]
boy I want to have great handle speed
with balls and must I'm pretty good at
Naturally defending I just like to have
steel to you know be able to have glove
or Interceptor at least speed Accel is
already maxed strength is really
important so get that a movable enforcer
on 90 I tell I play a
lot pretty complete build I like to get
a lot of on ball steals play Lanes get
into the rim doing all kind of funky
layups similar to Drew holiday i' would
say crossover I think I like Zach's
we're going go with my behind the back
put the jumper on it and we're good I
think I had
bogey Kobe got throw this on you know
what I'm saying just so I don't be booty
cheeks in the Gatorade gym this is uh my
jump shot you guys can steal it if you
want going to head to the New Balance
store right now switch up the swag I'm
wearing the 550s right now so I'm going
to throw those on some basic
joggers got to have me an oversized
shirt I'm at the gator AG gym right now
1 V one is my thing I play 1 V one more
than anything growing up 2K 5 was my
was my jam for sure I played a lot of
that look at that he doesn't know what
to do watch his Euro
hey I travel with my PlayStation every
time every trip anytime I'm indoors I'm
I'm on the game also helps me in real
life steal a couple moves or two maybe
you know L1
L1 that's
tough yoke one time he got the ball on
the post the guy fouled him no call the
very next possession yoke goes to the
ref I'm going to catch the ball I'm
going to face up I'm going to shoot and
he's going to go like this it's going to
be a foul same exact thing happened and
one side
[Music]
step obviously I'm going to play
alongside me you know what I'm saying
we're going to be a crazy onew punch of
Jamal Murray with Jamal Murray that's
going to go
crazy in real life that' be stupid did
you look up to any other Canadian
players you made it the NBA when you
were growing up you know when I was
young in Nash and uh was the guy I
remember watching you know his games
growing up and then you know when I got
closer to to college you know Wiggins
was the guy Tyler Andis to name a few
Anthony Bennett we've always had the
talent it's just a matter of you know
getting eyes and getting them to have
the opportunity in America to to make
the league and all that so
congratulations I appreciate it Be A
Champion yes sir you kind of got to go
defend the title you know it's nice once
you get it it's relieving but you can't
be content you know there's teams
gearing up to try I beat you so try to
have a chip on our shoulder knowing that
we got a Target on our backs but we
can't think about last year and how
great last year was you know we got to
try to repeat
[Music]
it